okay so here's another thing I want to
talk about and we're gonna tiptoe
through it tiptoe through it and then
you'll reveal what you want to really
know and what you don't want to reveal
okay okay but I have a little problem
with a female comedian from Chicago ooh
beef and like is it Twitter beef or like
real life I realize you have nothing to
do with what I'm about to say so you
could you stay out of it
okay but what's the girl's name yeah you
say that's why I'm asking you the whole
time I smoked a lot of pot and I did
smoke tonight after my Zumba class okay
so there is a girl that I I did the
Chicago improv and I had this big ups to
Tony yeah because why doesn't she remain
nameless it's so that way we can really
talk [ __ ] okay all right so I don't know
when a yeah that's great so she first
she showed up sweating like a lot like
she was hosting my shows this is a
couple years ago and she showed up to
one show wearing a ballroom gown no no
no what was it we show up and we think
she's the manager cuz she's like very
dressed up like she's wearing like a
night dress like it's shiny it's satin
and she's wearing like pearls I think
yeah and I do tricks to my features I
don't Jade has not because she is I
don't know maybe it's no you've done
[ __ ] you have the thing wait they would
call my name and you wouldn't let me go
on stage yeah do that yeah yeah I do
that a lot but guess what I can do any
Club people don't do that to me now so
it's I'm a lot better yeah right I mean
you I'm trying to teach these kids I
started at the Comedy Store and yeah and
you're and you're hardened so you you're
into hazing yeah yeah like you know some
of the african-american comics like Doc
Willis I would say stuff like um you
have to say yabba-dabba-doo ten times
out front what's out justifying like a
joke hearted it's never like I feel
weird
so what happened with this girl so then
I go on hey just can you not dressed
like that
we were doesn't mean upfront we were
joking nobody didn't it's my show yeah
sorry it's my show and it's like I'm
just saying that like you know it's like
you know when
Radiohead plays I'm not saying that I'm
nowhere I mean obviously it's like blink
182 our local band performance Chad
Kroeger play for baby back Nickelback
really all right let's go Hoobastank
they get to choose who opens from them
and stuff right because it's a if
someone is headlining they if the whole
show is revolved around the headlining
show so I just go can you just dress it
down a bit it's just to my audience
you're growing up like you know in a
gown
you know just wear some jeans and a
t-shirt and we're cool and she just was
completely offended by it
yeah very offended how did you say it
though what do you mean I mean did you
establish a rapport before you told her
[ __ ] don't dress like that
no okay Bobby I would she didn't know
who he was and I could see how she could
have been like me too but she was very
dressed up I really I thought she was
the manager yeah but what if she was you
know what if that's her thing it is her
thing
it is her thing yeah well not anymore as
much no I I saw her a couple of months
ago we did a show in the belly room and
it completely forgot what she had looked
like and so she was hosting the show and
then afterwards I'm in the green room
upstairs in the converse door and she
walks up like tiptoeing she they
remember me she goes yeah I was that
girl from Chicago and she was wearing
jeans yeah she dress up because she
realized that it's stupid anyway so cuts
you so then Sunday night right Sunday
night she leaves the club and I think
she hates me right yeah Friday the first
night we think we're mean to her we feel
bad we feel bad and then Sunday night
I'm with the sound guy and he's really
called it really cool girl he texts the
sound guy saying no no no this what
happened we texted all of him her and
somebody else hey we're all gonna go to
dinner alright cuz we felt really bad
don't show her that we thought she was
cool and she was
yeah and then she says him she meant to
text just the sound guy back tax it Oh
everybody that's right that's where
that's what happened and she said that
dad Bobby Lee is she said no way I would
never want to hang out with them they're
taxing I think she might have said an
talentless but I don't think exactly
that she but she did she said taxing she
was like I don't wanna hang out with
them they're taxing yeah and you know
what that's fine
taxi I am taxing you guys respond no oh
yeah yeah like you wouldn't know like oh
this is how the sound guy I call he I
made him call her on his phone
and then I talked she came down no we
talked to her we did life yeah she came
down we're downstairs in a better area
yeah she came down and she was she was
really apologetic and we were like
that's fine it's okay let's go let's go
I wish you know what in that in that
situation I would keep it real I'm sorry
I'm sorry I sent that but that's how I
feel I wouldn't apologize because like
it's exactly how I said no I'll come out
with you guys and then she disappears
but then but then you told me that's
flip-flopping what you did is really not
being true to her like what you told me
this weekend was is that she has a
friend yes who's kind of popular and
she's coming up right a very good female
comic that um doesn't like us because of
that yeah your hand price because of
Bobby I've been paying the price for
years listen on shows in New York
yeah like I'll go yeah people go Oh Jade
yeah yeah yeah and then I go what what
do you know what do you know and in this
story has just been totally been
socially so minor and all she talked
about on a podcast she told me yeah so I
invite this girl to coffee because I
feel bad I want to clear the air right
and over with something that over budget
really happen to her and she has no idea
what happened I mean what has he has has
she experienced nothing in this life for
that to affect her so greatly yeah I
think it is I think some people want a
reason to hate other people and she just
found that because she latched on to
attached on yeah I I had her over shoes
I was really sweet she was cold I gave
her a scarf from gap it was very
expensive sorry
and then this thing came up and she was
so pissed and yeah and then you know
I've tried I've tried to be like hey
let's just get coffee and that's very
unlike me yeah because I'm vicious I'm
Brazilian
yeah she's Brazilian and I'm just like
let's smoke a joint
but infuriates me because I mean you can
call me a lot of things I'm a fat lazy
you know I like sometimes in the high so
no reasons you know I I have my
character defects but you know I feel
like I'm pretty good to my openers and
I've helped a lot of people in comedy I
feel but um so she's sick you know
spreading these rumors that I'm like you
know a psychotic and craziness and
poisonous I love beef because really now
okay maybe thinking back like what if we
were just horrible to her and we don't
remember like is that a possibility okay
but in the world of comedy don't you
think that banters like that happen
every day with stranger and you wouldn't
you would think that this girl is from
New York she would have a little bit of
Chicago or Chicago even more I mean
Ellie people are a little bit of [ __ ]
but over there in Chicago you know you
would think that she would have a little
bit more laughter a beer
yeah I don't want any beef I want it to
be fun that's why I do what I that's why
I do comedy for a living yeah you know
and I mean yeah can you hear the dog
yeah but do people hate it I know we had
a puppy lady come over this morning
I don't know trainer I had to wake up
and oh god yeah wake up at noon and god
forbid
oh my god Bobby listening and listening
to her have a sleeve about you know what
I needed to be doing we're about to get
tenants they have dogs I'm so scared
I'll just kill them the night
[Laughter]
[Music]